في السعوديه تنتهي الاثنين المقبل مهله
التسجيل للنظاميه للاراضي البيضاء والتي
تشمل في مرحله الثانيه الاراضي المطوره
بمساحه 10 الاف متر مربع واكثر في مكه
وجده وحاضره الدمام برنامج الاراضي
البيضاء اكد ان غرامه الامتناع عن التسجيل
خلال المهله المحدده تصل الى 100% من قيمه
الرسم ويهدف البرنامج المخصص للاراضي
السكنيه الفضاء الى تحقيق التوازن بين
العرض
والطلب
عود مره اخرى الى ضيف هنا المهندس عبد
الحميد محمد الرئيس التنفيذ لبرنامج رسوم
الاراضي البيضاء مهندس مرحبا بك معي في
نشات الرابعه اهلا وسهلا اكثر من 20 مليون
متر مربع في ثلاث مدن نتحدث عن جده عن مكه
الدمام
المقبل كيف تراقبنا الوضع حتى الان جميل
الله يحفظك انه اليوم برنامج الرسوم
الاراضي احنا نتحرك
مجموعه من اهداف المذكوره والموصوف عليها
في النظام قدكم ابرزها موضوع زياده العرض
همم
زياده المعروض العقاري في السوق بالاضافه
الى مكافحه ممارسه الاحتكاريه طبعا ما
يخفى عليك مثل انهم مثل فضلات الله يحفظكم
انه يوم الاثنين القادم راح تنتهي مهله
التسجيل همم موافقه 19 ديسمبر و25 جماد
الاولى همم مهره التسجيل النظاميه اللي
ذكرت النظام هي المهلهل النظاميه اللي
يسمح فيها الملاك الاراضي المطوره المرحله
الثانيه في جده ومكه والدمام اللي هي
مجموعها 10000 مربع فاكثر اما مجموعه
10.000 في مخطط واحد همم في التسجيل في
المناص الالكترونيه بعدين انتهاء من هذا
التاريخ
تروح تتسجل راح تعتبر اراضي مخالفه طبعا
بالمقابله الله يحفظك ذكرت جزيئه ال 20
مليون المربع في مجموعه ثلاث مدن هذه طبعا
ما يخفى عليكم من الرقم هذا يزيد وينقص
بمعنى انه متوقع ان شاء الله انه الرقم
هذا يكون اعلى من ذلك همم موزع على هذه
ثلاث مدن لكن بالمقابل 20 مليون مربع هذه
همم راح تضخ او راح بعد بعد فرض الرسوم
عليها نعتقد انه باذن الله راح تضخ اكثر
من حوالي 60,000 وحده سكنيه فهذا اشاره
متوقعه خلال السنه القادمه باذن الله ومن
هو متوقع ان شاء الله ان يكون فيه همم
الاعلان الرسمي عن الفوتر الرسميه باذن
الله يعني همم طيب في اواخر ديسمبر الحالي
باذن الله كيف تحدد النطاق المستهدف في في
هذه المدن هل هي ذات المعايير التي انطبقت
مثلا في المرحله الاولى خلينا ناخذ رياضه
على سبيل المثال هل ذات المعايير تنطبق
على هذه المدن الثلاث ايضا يخف عليك الله
يحفظك انه يمكن رسم النطاق نفسه همم
لتحديد مناطق فرض الرسوم فيها يعتمد على
مجموعه كبيره من المعايير
ابرزها موضوع فجره العرض الطلب احنا اليوم
مثلا في مثلا في جده او مكه لما نجي الله
يحفظك ونجي النقيس حجم نطاق اللي احنا
نحتاجه ان احنا نضخ مزيده
عندنا مجموعه من المعايير منها
شجره العرض الطلب بعد ذلك لما يكون عندي
قياس محدد للحجم اللي انا احتاج اني اضخها
في سوق المعرف عقاري يكون عندنا حصر من
خلال الاقمار الصناعيه ونغمج الجايس
الجغرافيه لمجموعه من الاراضي داخل هذه
الاحياء بعد حصرها همم يكون في طبعا تنسيق
معناه المدن والحياه الملكيه لتوجيه
التنميه العمرانيه بمعنى اخر يوم احنا
نعتبر انه برنامج رسوم الاراضي البيضاء هو
اداه فاعله لتوجيه الثمن عمرانيه في اي
مدينه كانت ممتاز قبل شوي احنا في في
الخبر قلنا انه ممكن الرسول تزيد بنسبه
100% باختصار اذا سمحت كيف يكون اختلاف
تغليض العقوبه طبعا هو الموضوع جزيره 100%
هذه المخالفات طبعا المخالفات في مجموعه
المخالفات خليكم ابرازه موضوع مخالفه عدم
تسجيل وعدم الفصاحه الملكيه العقاريه
وبالتالي همم اي ارض راح تسجل في مكه وجده
والدمام هذه المرحله الثانيه بعد اليوم
الاثنين القادم همم 16 ديسمبر رحت تعتبر
مخالفه اراضي مخالفه قد تصل فيها
المخالفات هي نسبه 100% قد تكون اقل طبعا
حسب ما تراه اللجنه المختص في ذلك اللي هي
الرسوم
الفاتوره نفسها ممتازه اشكرك جزيلا شكرا
على حضورك معي هنا في الاستديو الرئيس
التنفيذي لبرنامج رسوم الاراضي البيضاء
المهندس عبد الحميد الحماد جزيلا لك